the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones season
9 video
as you all know i have been writing my
own version of game of thrones season 9.
i have made four other episodes so far
but now i will show you what happens in
my next one
shall we begin this is game of thrones
season 9 episode 5 which i have named
the old gods in the very first scene of
this episode the sky is beginning to get
dark as the sun slowly slips behind the
horizon
off into the distance we can see there
is a gigantic castle
on the far side of the lake we're in a
location we have never been before
we're on the shore of the god's eye
somewhere we have only seen glimpses of
in brian stark's flashbacks
this evening is eerily silent the only
thing we can hear is the sound of the
red leaves rustling in the wind
and the water gently splashing against
the rocks
in the middle of this lake is an island
known as the isle of
faces as we look out across the lake
onto the island
all we can see are the faces on the
werewolves a thousand blood-red eyes are
staring back at us
eyes that look as if they're full of
ancient wisdom and secrets older than
the land itself
the faces on these werewoods are
different than the ones we have seen in
the north
they look frightening almost like
they've witnessed all of the atrocities
throughout the history of westeros
there is something very unsettling about
them it looks as if the werewolves are
guarding the sacred isle of faces
themselves
there must be hundreds of them standing
side by side surrounding the entire
island in a circle
the werewoods look alive as the red
leaves dance in the wind
suddenly we start to see some movement
there are shadows shifting back and
forth behind the werewoods
we can hear the sound of branches
breaking underneath footsteps
hundreds of small green figures begin to
emerge from the woods
they're all wearing helmets that are
shaped like antlers their green and
brown skin
looks as if it's made from the leaves
these green men do not look like the
innocent children of the forest who were
hiding out in the north
these little green men have a ghastly
look about their faces
all of them are holding dragonglass
weapons in their hands
however they're not made from the black
obsidian we have always seen before
their dragonglass weapons are green and
some of them are even red
all of them begin to stand shoulder to
shoulder on the shore of the sacred isle
of faces
as the werewoods stand guard over the
island the green men
stand there silently watching over the
werewoods behind them
it would be very difficult for anyone to
get onto this island
unless you are welcomed here in the
following scene we go back to king's
landing where a crowd is gathered below
the red keep
there are now men and women everywhere
the new city watch is standing around
sar brawn's lifeless body
as they hold everyone back we see
brienne walking around
asking everyone questions in hopes of
finding out what they all saw
and heard her hand is still resting on
the hilt of her sword
the city watch make way for samwell who
is holding his hand
over his mouth while he throws a blanket
over brawn
a few of the stark guardsmen lift his
body off the ground before they lay it
down on the back of a wagon
the onlookers are still shocked by the
gruesome scene
the shape of bronze body can still be
seen on the ground
where he was outlined by bits of his own
bone and large amounts of blood
some of bronze hair can even be seen on
the stone street below the red key
lore tyrion is standing there speechless
as he watches his friend's body get
hauled away
he finally snaps out of his days as he
hears a soft whisper behind him
say i saw what happened my lord i saw it
with my own eyes
now tyrion looks over his shoulder
wondering where the voice came from the
only one standing there behind him
is a short man dressed in rags he
doesn't say anything at first
he looks over at sam and brienne sam is
kneeling down
looking at something on the ground
brianne is still standing there
only now she's speaking to one of the
stark guardsmen not knowing what this
man will say
tyrion doesn't want everyone overhearing
him when he sees that the others are
still busy he looks back over at the man
and says follow me they begin walking
away from the scene
they don't walk far before they find a
building they can slip behind out of
sight
he grabs the man by his wrist before
asking him
what did you see i want you to tell me
every detail
the man looks down at tyrion then says
he was thrown off the balcony my lord
i was standing right below the red keep
when i suddenly heard a few voices
shouting from above
when i looked up i saw three men
standing there it looked like they were
arguing about something
it all happened so fast the next thing i
know
the men began shoving each other but
only one of them went over the railing
while letting go of the man's wrist
tyrion asks him who are the other men
do you remember what they look like or
what they were wearing i do my lord
says the man dressed in rags let me show
you they step back
out from behind the building the man
looks over where the crowd is still
gathered around
he holds out his finger in front of him
then says they look just like him
when tyrion follows the man's eyes and
finger he can see exactly who he was
referring to
they're now looking at one of the stark
guardsmen reluctantly
tyrion says i was afraid you would say
that now he steps in closer to the man
in a low whisper he says did you happen
to see anyone else out there on the
balcony
someone that might have been sitting
down the man suddenly gets nervous
as he realizes the gravity of the
situation
no my lord i did not see anyone else
tyrion now looks away
while silently letting out a sigh of
relief he looks back at the man
then says do not speak to anyone else
about this without speaking to me
first do you understand the man nods his
head
then says of course my lord he then
throws the man a small sack of golden
dragons
and says that should be enough to buy
your silence for now
what is your name the man says my name
is damian my lord
thank you for the information says
tyrion i may need you again
before all of this is over where can i
find you that won't be very hard my lord
says damian i live in flee bottom in the
only house that's still standing
the man in rags then bows his head
before the men go their separate ways
now tyrion begins walking back over to
where brienne is standing
he starts asking her what she has heard
what is everyone saying about what
happened
brienne says i find it a little hard to
believe but they're all saying he fell
on his own
there had to be someone standing out
here that saw something else
very well says tyrion if that's what
they saw then that's what they saw
this makes brienne glance over at him
out of the corner of her eye
it's obvious she doesn't feel the same
way he then looks over at samwell
who is still kneeling down looking at
the ground he watches as sam grabs
something off the ground before standing
back
up samwell is holding something in his
hand as he walks in their direction
when he stops in front of them he holds
it up into the air for them to see
it's a black feather that has blood
dripping down from it
it was laying under braun's body samwell
says nervously
when tyrion realizes what it is his
mouth hangs open
as he looks back up at the red key his
eyes find the balcony that braun fell
from
it's no longer empty bran is now sitting
out there alone
staring back at them the scene ends when
tyrion notices he is staring
right at him in the following scene we
are back in the darkness
deep below the ground somewhere in the
north there are
shadows dancing across the cavern walls
as the flickering flames
illuminate what lies ahead jon ghost
tormund
and helen reed follow the red and white
roots of the weirwood
as they make their way further and
further south ghost is still only a few
feet in front of them leading the way
as the men continue walking john looks
back over at allen reed
then says there are still a few things i
need you to help me understand
you said bran knew that daenerys would
burn king's landing before we ever went
south
you said he knew that i would be sent
back out beyond the wall
how did he know i know bran can see
things but how does he see them before
they happen
helen reed begins running his fingers
along the werewood roots as he walks
alongside john
he says your brother was given this gift
from the oldest gods in westeros jon
snow
the children have gods of the forest
rivers and stone
the old gods whose names are secret
their knowledge and wisdom runs deeper
than these roots
and where they go their eyes go as well
they are in harmony with everything
around us
when the children gave the weirwoods
their faces it gave them the ability to
see what they
see but after thousands of years they're
able to see so much more jon snow
your brother bran is one of their
greenseers he began by looking through
the eyes of the werewood
but now he can see so much more as well
john suddenly stops
walking he wipes the sweat from his brow
as he gathers his thoughts
if you're right about all of this then
they know we're on our way
john says dreadfully how can we ever
hope to stop them if they're already
half a dozen steps ahead of us
helen reed sets his hand on john's
shoulder than says i won't lie to you
jon snow
it won't be easy nothing ever is bran is
still in king's landing right now
surrounded by your friends as long as we
can reach him before he leaves
we still stand a fighting chance bran
has seen glimpses of the future
in his vision since he was a boy but he
hasn't seen everything
he hasn't seen you when the night king
attacked the cave
he forced your brother to go south while
he was still learning how to use his new
gift
the children of the south are now
fighting the children of the north over
your brother's mind
they're like a virus entering his body
infecting
everything he sees the further your
brother goes south
and the longer he's there the more and
more he loses of himself
it won't be long before he can no longer
control his own thoughts or
actions hold on says john you said bran
hasn't seen me
what did you mean by that helen reed
smiles and says
the old gods have your brother now but
they no longer have you
not like they once did you were
resurrected by the lord of light jon
snow
the same as daenerys targaryen when bran
sees either of you
and his visions now he's looking at
things that have already happened
that's why he's still in king's landing
the scene ends after hallam reed says
he doesn't know you or daenerys are on
your way
let's hope that doesn't change that's
our only advantage right now
in the next scene we go back across the
narrow sea
in the city of atlantis the sun is
sweltering on this afternoon
as it sits high in the sky above about a
dozen ships that are anchored along the
shore
the black and red sails of house
targaryen are dancing in the sky
as the wind slams against them throwing
them in the other direction
it almost looks as if the three-headed
dragons have taken flight
we watch as greyworm and a handful of
other unsolid men
walk across the deck as they make their
way into the city
grey worm has a slight smile on his face
he only focuses on the enormous red
temple of her lore
as he walks further and further down the
street it's sitting high up on its hill
looming over everyone below sitting
above everything else is drogon
he stretches his wings far and wide as
he soaks up the rising sun
everyone is waiting for daenerys
targaryen to emerge from the red temple
the 1000 slave soldiers of the fiery
hand are standing guard outside its
massive walls
eagerly awaiting their new orders the
crowd below them has been growing
thicker by the day
greyworm and his men remove their
helmets when they reach the city square
they can see the main entrance and its
great wooden doors that are engraved
with relore's burning heart
one of the slave soldiers of the fiery
hand stops them from getting any closer
they wait and watch with everyone else
suddenly
the large wooden doors swing open a man
in a red silk robe emerges from within
the crowd erupts when they begin
shouting his name bonero
bonero banero the unsolid men look
around
unsure of what's happening as bonero
raises his arms in the sky
everyone grows silent in a thunderous
voice
he says daenerys stormborn is the
fulfillment of an ancient prophecy
from smoke and salt she was born to make
the world anew
she is azor ahai returned and her
triumph over the great other
will bring a summer that will never end
and death itself will bend its knee
and all those who die fighting in her
cause shall be reborn
as daenerys was reborn before your very
own eyes
darkness has fallen heavy over the realm
but that darkness will flee
before her on this day we will set sail
for westeros
and we shall not return until the great
other is consumed by relore's great
flames
there are six more red robes that emerge
from within the red temple
as daenerys removes her hood greyworm's
eyes begin filling with water
he lets out a long sigh of relief
daenerys begins walking down the long
stone steps
followed by all of relore's highest
ranking members
when they reach the street the fiery
hand falls in around them
as they escort daenerys kinvara bonero
and the others to their waiting ships
drogon lets out another loud shriek
before leaping high into the sky
greyworm
and his unsullied men can only watch as
daenerys is marched right by them
as dany nears the shore of atlantis she
suddenly stops in her tracks when she
sees the black and red sails of house
targaryen
among the other ships there's at least
100 more ships docked
each of them displaying the burning
heart of her lore on their sails and
banners
daenerys begins looking through the
crowd wondering who brought them here
when she spins around her and greyworm
lock eyes
now hers begin filling with water they
embrace each other for a few moments
before danny says
i wasn't sure if i would ever see you
again how did you know i was here
i found out from a man on the island of
noth says greyworm
oh i see says daenerys with grief in her
voice
she holds his hand then says i wish i
could have been there with you when you
said goodbye
i should have been at your side when jon
snow betrayed you says grey worm
if you will allow me i would like to be
at your side again
i will follow you until my last day your
grace i have nowhere else to go
with a smile on her face daenerys says
then we shall sail together
i still have unfinished business in
westeros
the scene ends as daenerys and greyworm
walk across the sand
over to their ships in the following
scene we are on a different ship
as it reaches the southern shore in
westeros arya stark walks across the
deck
as the men get ready to drop its anchor
they have made it to their destination
arya watches as the waves crash against
the rocks below an enormous castle
she has only heard about in stories the
wall is said to be 40 feet thick at its
narrowest
in near 80 on the seaward face within
that mighty ball work
the kitchens and stables and yards
sheltered safe from the wind and wave
of towers there was but one a massive
drum tower
windowless where it faced the sea so
large that it was granary and barracks
in feast hall
and lord's dwelling all in one it is
crowned by massive battlements that made
it look from afar
like a spiked fist atop the up thrust
arm
as arya looks at all of her surroundings
the ship's captain walks over and stands
beside her
welcome to storm's end my lady says the
captain
it is said that this castle was built by
the same man who constructed your
family's ancestral home
did you know that my lady yes says arya
it was brandon the builder with the help
of the children of the forest
right azaria says this they hear a loud
shriek from above
arya has to shield her eyes from the
bright morning sun
as she looks up into the sky circling
right above them
is the same raven that has been
following them for several weeks
when arya looks back down she says don't
wait for me
i thank you for bringing me this far but
i will not be boarding the ship again
i will go to king's landing by horse
from here
i am sorry i can't be a further service
my lady but as you wish
says the captain he then bows his head
before he walks away
this is when arya notices several men on
horseback riding her way
one of these men is holding a banner
that shows the stag of house baratheon
arya smiles then makes her way off the
ship
as she walks across the sand only one of
the riders approaches her
while the others wait on the other side
of the beach i saw your sails
early this morning i was wondering why
there was a stark ship this far
south i was not expecting it to be you
my lady
i thought you were heading west says
gendry with a big smile on his face
i was says arya i changed my mind
well i hope you changed your mind about
accepting my offer
says gendry arya cracks a thin smile
but she says no it's not that something
else came up
and i may need your help gendry stopped
smiling when he says
this sounds serious what the hell
happened it's my brother bran
i think something is wrong with him says
arya gendry hops down off the horse
before asking her
did something happen to bran is he okay
well i'm not exactly sure cezaria
it doesn't make any sense but i think
bran wants me dead
there is several more moments of silence
before gendry says
this is very serious what makes you
think he wants you dead
the man who tried to kill me said he did
says arya maybe the man was lying
says gendry maybe he did lie says arya
but what if he wasn't
not to mention that's not the only thing
that happened
a raven has been following me after
several more seconds of silence
gendry says a raven what does that mean
well if you ride with me to king's
landing you will see
cesario okay says gendry i will go
but what do you want me to do once we
get there i don't know cesaria
i don't know what to do about this that
seems obvious says gendry
the fact that you're even here asking me
for help says that you don't know what
to do about this situation
i know one thing says arya i need to
speak with bran myself
i need to look him in his eyes and ask
him why
if there is something wrong with your
brother and he does want you dead
then he might not let you enter king's
landing so easily says gendry
the city will be guarded the scene ends
as gendry says
should i bring some of my men with us my
lady
in the next scene we go back below the
ground somewhere in the north
we're following john ghost tormund and
helen reed
as they make their way through the
darkness further and further south
the red eyes of ghost are glowing in
their flickering flames
the albino direwolf leads them through
the dark abyss
with the men following closely behind as
they're walking
tormund giantsbane looks to hell and
read and says when will this end
it feels like we have been walking down
here for days
well that depends on where you want to
go says helen reed
you can access almost any location in
westeros
using this cave system the children of
the forest dug these out thousands of
years ago
even before the first men arrived in
their lands
all we need to do is keep following the
werewolf south we will get there much
faster than any man would by horse
when we do get there says john what will
we do we don't have an army
it doesn't sound like the children of
the forest want to negotiate
they already made the night king it
frightens me to think of what else they
might be able to do
how will we stop them how will we save
my brother bran
helen reed doesn't say anything at first
he just keeps walking with his head down
as he slings the item he has been
carrying on his back
over his other shoulder finally after
what felt like several minutes
helen reed looks over at jon then says
we will have to make our sacrifices jon
snow
as i have said before it won't be easy
stopping these children of the forest
will come with a heavy cost
we won't be able to end this without
daenerys targaryen and her dragon
this makes jon think about when he last
saw daenerys when he stabbed her while
they were standing in front of the iron
throne
he thinks about what that choice cost
him he looks over at tormund giantsbane
he thinks about what it cost him when he
let the wildlings through the wall at
castle black
he then looks over at hal and reid who
is adjusting the large item on his
shoulder again
and says what sacrifices have you made
my lord
again there is several moments of
silence before helen reed says anything
helen reed looks into john's eyes then
says
there were many jon snow unfortunately
i made a great sacrifice that has cost
me dearly
with grief in his voice helen reed says
i had to sacrifice my very own but
before he can finish his sentence
some noises are heard in the distance
the hair on the back of ghost starts to
stand up
as his glowing red eyes cut through the
darkness ahead
jon grabs longclaw unsure of what
they're about to face
they can see there is some light
bouncing off the walls about a hundred
feet in front of them
there are a few shadowy figures moving
behind their light
jon looks at them with a hint of fear in
his eyes they're not able to make out
anyone's faces
that's when he shouts make yourself
known before you take another step
who are you why are you down here
suddenly they hear a voice shout back at
them
we are here on behalf of our queen sansa
stark
who goes there this scene ends as jon
says
i am her brother jon snow in the
following scene we go back down to
king's landing
a full moon sits high above the red keep
we watch as the hand of the king
tyrion lannister reluctantly walks
across the great hall
there are hundreds of ravens all over
the old throne room
since there is still a very large hole
in the side of the red keep the ravens
are able to fly
in and out of the great hall with ease
they all begin shrieking at tyrion
who feels an enormous sense of dread as
he makes his way to king bran's chambers
he knows this will not be an easy
conversation but he has to ask
bran himself what happened why did braun
die so suddenly
there are three star guardsmen standing
outside of brian's door
a few of them are the same stark men who
were drinking with brawn at the end
one of them says we have been expecting
you lord tyrion
why would you be expecting me as tyrion
as the stark guardsman opens the door
he says you will see go ahead and step
inside
as he walks into bran's chambers the
stark guardsman follows behind him
when they're all inside they shut the
door lord tyrion watches nervously
as one of them locks it when he looks
across the room
he sees bran sitting there in his chair
silently gazing into the fire
he sees there is even more stark
guardsmen inside the room with them
one of the stark guardsmen throws
something from across the room
it lands in front of tyrion's feet
spilling out onto the floor
when he looks down he sees there is a
small sack
with golden dragons all around it when
he looks back
up bran is staring into his eyes with a
very unsettling look about his face
it makes tyrion feel uneasy as he tries
to figure out what's happening
that's when the stark guardsmen near
bran step aside
revealing there has been someone
standing behind them laura tyrion
immediately recognizes the man who is
dressed in rags
it's damien the man who said he
witnessed braun's death
his hands are bound at the wrist his
face has been bloodied
and bruised even the front of his pants
are soaking wet
finally tyrion asks bran what is the
meaning of this
with a smile on his face bran says
where were you lord tyrion where was you
at when braun fell
i was in my chambers sir brianne was
there with me says tyrion
why are you asking me this damien
flinches as one of the stark guardsmen
throws his arm around his shoulder
this dark guardsman says that's not what
our new friend has been telling us
really cysterian as he looks at all of
damien's injuries
he says he doesn't look like a new
friend he looks like a dog that has had
all the fight whipped right out of him
he then looks back at bran
and says what did you force him to say
about me
the man said you gave him those golden
dragons to have sir braun murdered
says brynn this is nonsense y'alls
tyrion
why would i want my own friend dead i
gave him that so i could buy his
silencer grace
we know you did says one of the star
guardsmen you needed his silence so he
would keep your secrets safe
we know that now no yells tyrion
that's not how it happened while looking
at bran he says
i wanted him to keep your secret safe
your grace
i did not want all of king's landing
thinking the new king
was involved in murdering one of his own
council members before i could find out
what really happened
this entire country has been through
enough the mad king
the drunken king robert the sadistic
joffrey
my sister cersei and that was before
daenerys burnt king's landing down to
the ground
i thought we were finally done with all
of this i did not want everyone thinking
we were back to our old ways of
backstabbing and murdering each other
i guess i was wrong again
what has happened to you bran i thought
you would be great for the realm
king brain has a haunting look in his
eyes it's as if all of his life has left
them
the scene ends after brain says what
happened to bran
he died in a cave years ago he looks at
one of the stark guardsmen
then says have lord tyrion thrown into
the black cells
he will be executed for the murder of
sir brawn of highgarden
in the final scene of this episode we go
back to the isle of faces
all of the red leaves on the werewoods
are illuminated from the full moon that
hangs high in the sky
above the god's eye the green men are
still silently standing their watch over
the sacred island
we won't be focusing on them in this
final scene however now we move inward
into the center of the island where the
woods are much denser than they are
on the shore of the lake the shrieking
sound of ravens can be heard from the
branches above
in the very center of the isle of faces
there is a massive weirwood
standing over 300 feet tall and nearly
30 foot wide
at its base the face on the front of it
has a mouth that's so big
a grown man could easily stand inside of
it
its eyes are frightening as it gazes
into the fire before it
surrounding the massive weirwood is a
grove of seven more werewoods
all facing inward at the fire this is
where the children of the forest would
hold their sacred ceremonies
and even their sacrifices to their gods
which they believe
are the werewolves themselves as the
flames in the fire crack and hiss
very large shadows begin to move all
around us
suddenly there are glowing blue eyes
emerging from the shadows around the
weirwood grove
the little green men are not the only
ones here
this is when we see there are dozens and
dozens of white walkers riding on the
backs of giant elks
whose eyes also have a blue glow to them
there is something slightly different
about these white walkers
they don't look exactly like all of the
other ones we have seen before
they're gaunt and heart as old bones
even their armor seems to change color
as they move around on their massive
elks one second
they look white as new fallen snow the
next second
they were black as a shadow white
shadows in the darkness
they have a sort of elegance to them
only in a very frightening kind of way
these white walkers are the children's
chosen ones
who were selected to guard their sacred
isle of faces
no one knows what they're capable of but
they will find out
soon enough
[Music]
[Music]
you